it's a new 101
why would I know sporty station chillin
with my man busy phone right now now
Andy shut down weekly because the
Knitting factor they were late thank you
one of the late baby I was running late
I think Miller was a curfew I'm used to
perform under the ground 11:00 and
sometimes people gives me time because
of my travel around this I'm catching
these crazy applies to these crazy
cities so disappointed in that because
poor service tonics and trying to keep
things going and will sequence all
tonight watch on the states are one over
yes yes
Nasus is such a beautiful thing that can
pick me up from the airport the reckful
and I'm thankful set aside this is all
bone thugs-n-harmony like for the table
one old way just so we know there we
know man what's what's the situation
with both dogs right now well I'm gonna
be honest which I like to tell everybody
the good news they just signed a deal
with Warner Brothers I just solidified
my and the water gets no more business
and friendship and you take care of your
business that they could get to kick it
with your other [__] friends and
that's kind of what's going on haven't
been getting along now oh man well
everyone was worried because let's go
back to jail that second gun charge but
what was really cool about it was his
wife is a certified police officer so
probation that do what they have to do
just motors elections out my goodness
just out everything is good crazy bald
is producing the record recording here
that crazy ones personal studios over
the next novel eyes met finished oh you
know high five it's gonna be a great
record
I just solidified the deal I'm very very
grateful very very thankful and I'm just
moving forward right now spitting swords
and keeping things
arretez mr. Bonin boys very appreciative
someone to make another one Thank You
Man directly and also of regular I'm off
in the know that everything is good
right now you allow me to appreciate on
their on their diligence and you know
they could've just said you know major
major little if you come out here and
Boise you come out here to the liquidus
is one of the coolest like this club so
all of the liquid we love you man that's
from our entire family and that's what
it is set aside that's how you see me
I mean I'm moving you guys